It's really useful to understand that
there are actual reasons why people see
the world differently and that you can't
just easily say that one is right and
the other is wrong because the liberals
are correct when it comes to borders,
that if you thicken them too much and
diminish the information flow,
you risk making the society so static
that any radical environmental
transformation will sink it.
It's the case,
but the conservatives are right in that
you pay a big price with regards to
newcomers and new information with
regards to risk to exposure to
contaminating while to contamination
period,
but also to contaminating ideas.
And so then I've always thought,
you know,
the,
the environment itself moves back and
forth like a snake in some sense.
And what we're trying to do is stay on
the center of its back.
And the only way we can do that is by
people,
by having people pull to the right and
say,
be careful.
And people pull to the left and say,
well yeah,
but be open with that dialogue and the,
the exchange of information that,
that dialogue allows,
we can maybe specify the center of that
moving target and stay and stay well and
stay on the back.
Let's,
yeah.
Okay.
So that's a really complicated metaphor
with the snake.
But I think it's a perfect way in to
what's going on on campus and to why
viewpoint diversity is so important.
Cause that's,
I agree exactly with what you just said.
And so what I,
the view that I've come to in studying
moral psychology is that we is that
humans are ultra social apes.
Um,
we,
we evolved to live in these small groups
that are fighting with each other.
Uh,
we evolve to have these low level
animistic religions.
That's our steady state.
That's the way we were for at least a
hundred thousand years are much more,
um,
probably closer to million in some form.
Um,
so that's sort of our design.
That's what we were designed for in a
sense.
Um,
and in that sense were as individuals
really kind of stupid tribal creatures
designed to do post hoc reasoning.
Um,
but if you put us together in the right
way with the right checks,
with the right,
the right systems,
um,
the,
the whole can be vastly smarter than the
components that go into it,
which is true of the brain to the brain
is composed of neurons.
Each neuron is really kind of stupid
little switch,
but you put them together in the right
way and you get something really
brilliant.
And in the same way,
um,
I don't know all the history here,
but my understanding is that science
begins or the culture of science,
the scientific revolution begins in
Europe in the 17th century.
As you begin getting,
you get the printing press so people can
share their ideas,
but you get communities of people who
are challenging each other's ideas.
And that's what makes it so brilliant is
that is that people have to do their
best.
We're really bad at this confirming our
own ideas.
It's very hard to make it very hard to
do that.
But you put your ideas out there and
then everyone else is motivated to
challenge them.
And so if you put us together in the
right way,
the truth comes out.
And so adversarial systems of law
journalists know this.
They have to listen to both sides.
Scientists know this.
Social scientists should know this.
Okay,
what happened?
Well,
um,
the academy has,
has always leaned left in the 20th
century,
but leaning isn't the problem.
So people think,
oh,
viewpoint diversity we need,
we need everybody.
We need Nazis.
We need every view.
No,
we don't need everybody.
What we need is no orthodoxy.
That's what's fatal orthodoxy.
So if you have a,
if you have to feel it like sociology or
social psychology in which it's two or
three,
two,
one left to right,
that's totally fine with me,
that's totally fine because if someone
makes some claim that's just like
ideologically blind,
someone will say,
uh,
you know,
common sense,
other evidence that you've missed and
then the system works.
But what,
what I learned when I started down this
road in 2011,
I gave a talk at the big conference of
social psychologists.
I gave a talk about this problem that
we're losing our diversity,
that I could only find one conservative
and the entire field and they gave a
talk on this.
Um,
and um,
um,
and so what I've learned since then is
that the ratio in psychology was between
two to one and four to one left,
right?
All the way up to the early nineties.
We've gathered together all of the
studies we could find.
So all the,
up to the early nineties,
it's only three or four to one left to
right,
which would be okay.
Um,
but then between 1995 or four and 2010,
it goes to a 14 to one.
Do you,
do you have any idea why and why that
time?
Yes.
So,
um,
so you get the same story.
Whether you look at Republican,
Democrat ratios or liberal conservative,
they're,
they tell the same story.
So the two of the big things going on,
there are one is that the greatest
generation,
which had a lot of Republicans,
um,
so a lot of men go off to World War II.
They are there on the Gi bill.
They entered the academy in the 1950s a
lot of them are conservative or
Republican.
Um,
so you have a lot of them.
But in the sixties and seventies,
one of the main reasons to go to Grad
school and the social sciences is either
a to stay in school to escape the
Vietnam war draft or be to fight for
social justice and against racism.
So in sociology and psychology in
particular in political science,
maybe,
I'm not sure you get a huge influx of
left leaning people who are there to
pursue social justice.
So you know,
the motives are fine and if it was
balanced and be totally fine,
but as you get these young junior people
on the left come in in the 70s and
eighties and then you get the older
people that are more politically
balanced,
retiring in the eighties and nineties.
By the time you get to the late
nineties,
it's all baby boomers.
And so do you get a,
you get a positive feedback loop
developing in there.
Like you said,
it's like three to one.
It's okay,
but maybe when it hits four to one,
it goes to like 20 to one,
then you stay.
Exactly.
So then,
so then you start getting hostile
climate.
So I wrote a review paper on this with
uh,
with Joe Duarte and Phil tetlock and
lead Justin,
jared Crawford.
Um,
um,
and um,
and we,
uh,
so we reviewed everything that we could
find and we concluded that most of
what's going on is self selection.
That is people on the left are more open
to experience.
They're always going to get self
selection.
But then there's really good evidence
that there's also hostile climate.
I mean it's,
it's undeniable now that if you are not
on the left in a Grad program,
there's just constant little subtle or
not so subtle reminders that you don't
belong.
And look in the academy,
we're all about saying,
Hey,
if there are subtle hints here and
there,
you can't succeed.
Right?
I mean,
that's what we do for a living is we say
that little things will stop people.
Um,
well,
little things are put in the way of
anyone who doesn't fit politically.
Uh,
and so you do get hostile climate.
You do get over discrimination.
There's evidence of that.